located on the mississippi river not far
from the gulf of mexico is the new
orleans suburb of metairie
a tight-knit community that is home to
zeke's a neighborhood restaurant opened
in 2002 by a charismatic entrepreneur
named zeke ognus
zeke was six foot four big and goofy but
you know what the man knew how to have a
good time and he knew how to run a
pretty good restaurant
everyone came to zeke when it first
opened because there was just a good
vibe in this place good people food was
always good
we used to do 750 people in here on a
friday night
but in 2005 zeke tragically died during
hurricane katrina and the ownership and
the direction of the restaurant was up
in the air after katrina this place was
in limbo
so the cortellos fought it and they
pretty much took on the place hi guys
how are y'all tonight welcome to zeke's
when we bought zeke's we chose to keep
the name because zekes did a very good
business and that just made business
sense to us all right guys first guest
when daryl first took over pretty much
changed everything
he cut staff he cut product he went to
uh lesser quality wouldn't feed that to
your dog and then on top of that he
raised the prices
it's a little over the top i feel as
though i'm completely handcuffed in the
kitchen i'd love to do like a steam
clams that's not us i don't think that's
us what i'm saying i'm always trying to
beg him or plum can we try that can we
do this and daryl doesn't allow it
trying to make chicken salad out of
chicken [ __ ] i ask myself all the time
why do i even stay here
i know sitting on the job
servers here are all talked down to or
disrespected people just don't feel
appreciated
daryl cut my pay in the last six months
i can't afford raises right now man it's
made me work more hours since he cut my
pay
that ro we got three orders of green
tomatoes left cutting them a little
thick too i tell you that i'm not
looking to squeak by i'm looking for
financial rewards in this business
that kind of offended a lot of zeke's
regulars and this was just steadily
declined
meatballs plain and bland unless he's
got a pot of gold stashed there's no way
this restaurant will last you know a
month
all right payroll was today how'd we do
that's not a good question
financially we are not doing great we
got to catch up somewhere it's not
happening we're not going to make it if
we don't have chef ramsay come in and
tell us what he thinks we can do
differently to change this because
obviously what we're doing it's not
really working
physically
emotionally it's been hard
i have put everything i can possibly put
in the zekes but seats aren't full so
something's going on and we're killing
ourselves trying to find out
before heading to zeke's gordon has
arranged to meet some metairie locals to
gain some insight into the restaurant
and the neighborhood oh doing good how
are we doing this morning very indeed
thank you morning
how are we
now tell me about the area metric what
does it uh what does it stand for it's a
town on east bay
they got a lot of people they got some
good russian sub there and have you
heard of restaurant called zeke's i used
to go there quite a bit i haven't been
in a while but before katrina we used to
go there quite a bit before katrina
would feel like every friday it was
great
what was the difference in food got
pricey in average already yeah the
quality has gone down quite a bit yeah
atmosphere wasn't the same they lost the
magic the feel of the restaurant right
just changed yeah thank you
thank you
after hearing unfavorable reviews chef
ramsay heads over to zeke's to continue
his investigation
and there is nothing more telling than
lunch
hello well hello chef frankie welcome to
zeke i'm very happy to be here helen
nice to meet you come right this way
all right guys i think we got a special
guest her dad heard that
help me get up to speed you are the
owner yeah
you run the business with zeke my
husband no my husband is daryl daryl
where is he he is in the kitchen
so
zeke was the original man who opened the
restaurant um passed away right after
katrina
and we purchased it from his estate so
we've had it for almost five years what
did you change after you bought it the
menu items are similar okay we've
definitely taken some off and changed
some recipes and the chef is the same
emil is the kitchen manager yes
decision is it with the new dishes my
husband daryl
he's got a couple of his recipes on the
menu and where did he train as a chef
he's never trained as a chef
[Music]
if you're not a chef why would you put
dishes on the menu
being in the business i guess okay does
the chef agree with those dishes or is
it just because he's the owner that's
what he gets them on
i guess talk to him about it okay let me
look at the menu okay thank you yeah
you're welcome
wow
hello hi how are you today how are you
i'm so happy to be in louisiana my first
time good thank you your first name is
candace
i saw on the menu the
oyster
cortello
it's an invented dish for our restaurant
the cortellos is daryl and ellen so they
made they made it up so the owners have
named an oyster after them can we bought
the restaurant now you want your name on
the menu yeah sounds like someone's
struggling for power ah
i've got to try one okay yeah i must
have some boiled shrimp boiled shrimp
and what special do you have my donny we
have a chicken fried steak today let's
go for it we do have also traditional
bread pudding
let's go for that and i think we're done
okay thank you
look what i got all right here we go
when daryl got here he kind of
implemented his own menu it really gets
frustrating because daryl really has no
idea culinary-wise what he's doing
candice you're ready i'm going to take
out the boiled shrimp to him
chef ramsay is going to love this food
it's simple food it's basic food it's
feel-good food but it's done very well
and fresh
okay boiled shrimp
thanks honey
my first louisiana shrimp
yeah everything's soft
they should peel easily and sort of pop
out the shell but i'm struggling to peel
them
[Music]
i mean that was nasty what i'm
struggling for here is the lack of
freshness they feel and taste slightly
mushy which is a big disappointment
can this were the shrimps fresh they're
fresh frozen fresh frozen
i know it's kind of an oxymoron but you
can buy fresh shrimp within a mile yes
yes the frozen shrimp tastes like [ __ ]
sorry crap
[Music]
he wanted to know why we would get
frozen shrimp when you can go to like
the market and get them fresh every day
it's not uncommon to have frozen shrimp
because some things are okay frozen have
a look on the oysters coming right now
all right
wow that back wall is hideous
what a mess
you got two seconds please yes and
what's with the uh
the swamp decor
whose idea was that um mine and my
husband to eat in a swamp
for children or for adults both for both
[Music]
voices
that's not words for me
[Music]
all right here we go okay thank you all
right what the hell is that these are
the oysters cortello oysters cortello
so suppose you go like that
wow there's dreadful
oysters named after the owner
i certainly would put my name on that i
wouldn't even put my enemies name on
there
take it for you okay thank you
that's depressing isn't it
no
just
terrible
oysters cortello i don't know what to
say about that i eat them myself i think
they're delicious
absolutely delicious daryl what do you
say oysters cortello just ain't working
[Music]
this is killing me not to know what he's
saying
this is the fried chicken snake right
correct thank you you're welcome
bland as anything no seasoning no care
look at that
candies what the hell is that it looks
like it's just had a giraffe's tongue
cut out and deep fat fried
people complain that the quality of the
food here is horrible
unbelievable daryl's not listening to
the feedback that he gets and he's going
to do what he wants to do
he said that it looks like somebody cut
out a giraffe's tongue battered and
fried it
i'm not going to agree with that it
didn't look that way to me i mean that's
what normally goes out
it's a good product
they look like we cut out a giraffe's
tongue
wow wow jesus thanks
it doesn't look fantastic
but it tastes delicious you made that
e-mail it makes it
i'm just so happy that chef ramsay likes
in the bread pudding it feels great to
end on a good note love the bread
pudding
you like the bread boy there we go
loved it
i took full responsibility for bread
pudding that is all me daryl doesn't
really have influence on that thank god
thank god he likes something i did
i'll take that any day
hello hello chef and this is daryl
the owner
introduce me to your uh brigade chef
emile marcos emil good to see you buddy
chase the carpenter jason good to see
you there's a lot of things that that
need changing and you know daryl is one
of them
can i talk about lunch yes
my god what a disaster
the food
is below standard
why wouldn't you buy fresh shrimp i
simply don't have the time to go to the
market
excuse me
where are we
come on
come on big boy
chicken fries steak disaster
what cut of meat was that not a very
good cut no are you proud to serve that
food no sir was that the same quality of
steak that we were using years ago no
sir and why have you changed the
standard
it's up to daryl
is that our cutting corner method to say
no chef everything is [ __ ] to you yeah
but we had diners eating all lunch full
dining room but nothing's sent back do
you honestly think just because they
don't send it back that your food is
[ __ ] amazing
that's good enough for you to continue
now you can't be that [ __ ] stupid
point taken if they want to be that
stupid you've got no chance
[Music]
i don't buy the fact that it's bad
quality food that's [ __ ]
hard to believe this was once a great
place
after receiving some harsh words from
chef ramsay the food
is below standard
daryl has some words of his own you know
chef says everything is [ __ ]
it's embarrassing there's nothing good
about the menu you know i don't buy that
[ __ ] i will never believe the food is
[ __ ] you're not gonna commit i've been
eating this food all my life chef ramsay
doesn't know the world and food that's
it
you cut all the food down you want you
can't break me
it's an hour before dinner service and
chef ramsay hopes a private meeting with
the two chefs emil and jason can shed
some light on the restaurant's main
issues
okay
so i don't get it
some of the things i encountered there
today were just awful that can't be your
wish to cook with frozen ingredients we
talk about every day and it just gets
swept under the table i tell him the
second he starts cutting the cost and
getting a cheaper product yeah you know
it's going to taste like [ __ ] and trying
to explain that to him yeah you know
it's like talking to this wall right
here and how long has it been going on
like that since the right around the
time he took over the only thing daryl
and ellen see is money
and that's what scares me their whole
purpose is money money money money money
we feel like our hands are so tied as
far as ordering goes everything goes the
only other option was to leave me and
him both go yes you know what do you do
just walk out the place i mean we got a
lot of personal memories in this place
just to walk out of it granted i i get
that but it doesn't stop you from having
your voice everybody here is just kind
of waiting for the place to belly up and
go find a new job somewhere else i'm
here to help put this freaking place
back on the map yes sir you're
absolutely right we have only two
options chef ramsay or god and i don't
think the second comments happen anytime
soon thanks for the ketchup
[Music]
after gaining some insight from jason
and emil hey i need shrimp portions chef
ramsay is eager to see how this
restaurant functions in a dinner service
how does this
work with these done um last night
why they bagged he poisoned them out to
order
ready
[Music]
what's the idea putting everything in
bags portion size portion size
i like to have everything in
quantitative perspective if i give too
much you get a happy customer here you
don't get a good customer they're happy
because they're getting three times what
they should be getting i'm getting
nothing i don't make money on that it's
food you know we're not cutting uh
piping
hi welcome to zeeks how many do we have
in the party
it's chef ramsay's first time in
louisiana come right this way please and
not surprisingly zeke's is completely
booked and tonight our specials is
lasagna
i got to see food plotting no oyster sub
shrimp i'm at the expo station i like to
see all the food go out inside of new
potatoes
i uh make sure every dish goes out like
i want it to go out can i run anything
nope
shrimp platter can only not go i'm
waiting on dishes to complete the order
it doesn't concern you the food's just
dying in the window but we're pushing as
hard as we can bloody hell
expediting is one thing standing here
and saying nothing is another
wow
it's an hour into dinner service and the
first wave of food is finally making its
way out to the customers sorry about the
weight they are about
everybody's food at the table as well
let me get your server my apologies and
the food isn't the only thing that's
getting a chilly reception can i ask
something do you mind not standing there
like that it's so dour i think you can
be more proactive i don't want to hover
you know but you can make yourself busy
okay i got it i'm ready
thank
[Music]
all you look what i got what's that one
lasagna lasagna when was the lasagna
made last thursday last thursday
and today's thursday right correct
[Music]
seven of stuff from a week ago
help me to understand that uh
that's stupidity
that made the pan we didn't sell it all
it's wrapped up in portions
i thought that's a bad thing lasagna
it's all done fresh and cooked and uh
we'll wrap the portions up separately or
put them in the freezer it works it is
the best lasagna you're going to get is
it special right yes it is okay so how
the [ __ ] is that special in your tiny
mind when it was cooked a week ago
i'm telling you have a tiny mind it
can't be that special if you're going to
stand here and tell me that this is
special the product is good
daryl runs his kitchen with 90 bravado
and you know the other 10 he just wings
it this is a good product this is good
food oh
my god it's getting worse
yeah he's a tough nut you're uh
expediter so we have a special today
when do you think that lasagna was made
today homemade lasagna right last
thursday
how could it be that special when it's
from a week ago well you know it's
frozen so it's not like sitting there
getting mildew on it and our customers
absolutely love the lasagna i don't
think that's our biggest issue is
lasagna i mean that's absolutely
incorrect what do you think they would
feel like if you told them today's
special was cooked a week ago frozen i
don't know i mean i'm sure they would
probably be surprised that it was so
good and that it was made last week in
frozen
[Music]
should i ask them all would you like me
to walk with you i know i'm not gonna
walk or stand up and shout
oh really
[Music]
[Music]
when you come out to restaurants and you
read today's specials for instance a
beautiful homemade lasagna would you
expect that lasagna to be made today yes
ladies and gentlemen how many of you
have ordered lasagna
how would you feel if i told you all
that
today's lasagna that's been served was
made a week ago
this is humiliating
after making a shocking discovery about
today's special what was the lasagna
mate last thursday chef ramsay made an
announcement
today's lasagna that's been served was
made a week ago
that is not sitting well with customers
my apologies to those that have ordered
the lasagna have a look at the potential
of the specials
bonneville t thank you thank you
this is humiliating it's absolutely
better of course when it's fresh and
served right out of the pan but it's not
horrible
i just told the customers that laser
sanya was reheated from a week ago
the
feedback was shock horror 86 lasagna yes
sir yeah
with chef ramsay's announcement fresh in
their minds
check okay customers have seemed to have
lost their appetite
did y'all eat already
yeah i had the lasagna
after witnessing a dinner service full
of problems
you got two seconds yes absolutely chef
ramsay is anxious to have a chat with
the owners
oh dear
did you hear the customers tonight
i told them lasagna was a week old did
you hear
here's what happens cook lasagna and it
doesn't sell you throw it away
no we don't throw it away we wrap it i'm
here to help but i tell you what i can't
help you when you're standing there and
trying to come up with excuses to why
customers pay good money for frozen [ __ ]
that cooked a week ago and you call it a
special we don't feel like it puts out
an awful product
[Music]
you don't give a [ __ ] about food that's
not true your passions about portion
control measurements frozen foods
reheating of microwave russians don't
run like this
disagree i disagree with that also
definitely
trust me you are not a [ __ ]
restauranteur
you're the owner you're paying rent here
when you start dealing with all this
crap and your name's on that lease then
you tell me what you want to do
[Music]
after being stonewalled by owners in
denial
good morning
chef ramsay is called a staff meeting
two minutes please hoping to bring all
the restaurants issues into the open
okay
i want you to tell me
the frustrations
the anger and the things that really
upset you the most
emil um
i just feel as though
i'm getting pounded with a mallet
constantly when i walk into this place
i went from working 40 hours to working
about 50
for 400 a week
that pisses me off
i feel that we don't get any respect
i'm here all the time i don't get to eat
lunch i should have a meal i should have
a chef meal this is messed up
we are talked down to like we're dirt
and it's not right
listen um i really appreciate the
openness and the honesty and it was bad
but i didn't quite understand it it hit
that level of
hurt i think it's just sad that we're
all sitting here and that we actually
have to even beat at this point
i think we all
the whole group of us here pretty much
struggling no one's getting that message
across
i need to get through to them
daryl
and ellen are about to arrive
i want you to tell them
everybody was saying what they wanted to
say and getting it off their chest but
it's kind of different from telling chef
ramsay versus telling daryl don't be
nervous i don't need to be afraid i've
got your back
okay
and here they are good morning good
morning
i've been here having a staff meeting
um
we've gone through some issues um this
morning that's been bothering them
but rather than
me trying to tell you how they feel
i think they should speak
certainly who's gonna go first
[Music]
i go first
i don't feel as though we all gain much
respect around here
and i don't think that
you as an owner have our back
candace ashley is that how you feel
you really do
talk to us like dirt sometimes my intent
is not to talk down to somebody but
that's how it comes out
jason
talk to daryl please my biggest problem
that i have is just i don't think you
have a clue as to how this place runs
me yeah
wow i think that you're so stuck on the
numbers the actual essence of having a
restaurant serving good food and giving
customer service and happy employees
that's gone i don't understand
we hear it every single night and every
single day from our customers what needs
to be changed and why they don't come
back
we let you know these things and you
don't give a [ __ ] nothing's done
you don't care
wow
hey pants is ridiculous here
i really don't wanna break down because
i
i've been in a long time
and i'm not getting pissed
check [ __ ]
for somebody to be here that long
[Music]
i've been here since
2006. why haven't i never got a pay
raise
okay let me say something real quick
since we're all telling the truth
first of all daryl and i have taken
thousands and thousands of dollars out
of our personal account to pay your
paychecks so why not just close the
place down we're not giving up we don't
want to give up if you want to give up
that's fine this isn't your business
we don't want to leave each other
because we all love each other we don't
want to leave
not at all but i need to make money to
support my family you know what so do we
y'all acting like it's us against y'all
and it's not
[Music]
this is a business we have costs and
expenses i ask you to take that pay cut
it's either that or labor costs get so
high i'm out but you can go on five
vacations in the summer and you're
struggling for money right
that is [ __ ] up
[Music]
period if you don't want to be here
don't be here
after chef ramsay arranged for the staff
to air their grievances i don't think
you have a clue as to how this place
runs the defiant owners are not having
any of it if you don't want to be here
don't be here
if i were piling up money back there
then i could see you being pissed off
but we're not piling up money back there
i can't show appreciation in dollars at
this point they maybe have this picture
of me with this pile of money going
hahaha nobody's going to get it we don't
have the money i'm accepting the truth
from you guys accept it from me please
[Music]
things aren't going well i understand
that in terms of morale there's an air
of discontent
they feel abused and i'm not saying the
staff are perfect but you're the owners
and you set an example
we have to fix what's broken within so
how about starting over again and
turning the page and
the beginning of a new chapter
i understand those frustrations
you're wonderful people so i want you
all here and you will have my respect i
guarantee that from me and there's a lot
of love for you guys from ellen and i
and i truly mean that
good we did make some progress videos
clearer
okay it's a new day here at zeke's i've
got some ideas that i need to uh put
into place to really start
putting this place back on the map thank
you
honestly i don't think that daryl and
ellen heard what what we were saying he
was just saying what was right just to
get chef ramsay off of his back
we'll see what happens
oh
after attempting to open daryl and
ellen's eyes to the staff morale
problems chef ramsay has devised a plan
to test the chefs and showcase their
abilities okay it's been so obvious
that you've been handcuffed by daryl and
here's what i want you to do
show
down how creative how inspirational how
exciting you can be with seafood there's
a grocery store literally
two miles away from here okay have a
look at the ingredients get inspired
come back get creative i want to see
that on a plate yeah thank you
good right now i'm pretty jacked up
gordon ramsay himself said jason time
for you to be inspired go let it happen
let's see what you got
all right let's see what they got fresh
how may i help you redfish fresh you
just put it out hour and a half ago
that's what we're looking for it's
extremely liberating to have this
freedom to showcase and do what we want
to do cook good food very nice to meet
you thanks guys i am uh looking for red
onions with uh asparagus let's do a red
pepper this will be the last thing i get
and we're ready to ride there it is it
is showcase the skills
[Music]
so happy think of something creative and
really let it go yeah yes okay off you
go guys yeah yeah i'm going to do a
chicken fried steak at the same time
okay brilliant
i own it yeah yeah sure you could put a
little lime juice in there yes
i'm not done yet with it okay good
i love the idea the bacon and cheddar
nice
[Music]
so in terms of the inspiration tell me
what it is try to keep it southern with
the grits fresh with the salmon and
classic with the capers with the onions
with the tomatoes good
keeping it with the new orleans theme
redfish and then grilled vegetables
fresh rice fresh ingredients just a fun
dish pretty good job the difference of
night and day let me tell you that
beautiful
now you say nothing you didn't cook them
i cook them do you understand yes okay
let's go
come over guys please
wow look at that
you think of louisiana first thing you
think of is freshness but when i walked
into your restaurant what i didn't
expect was frozen seafood
so i got my team to get some ingredients
from it
like you both just have a little taste
taste of freshness
a beautiful chocolate salmon done with
grits
creamy tasty it's absolutely phenomenal
and i got hold of some red fish marinade
zucchini with some rice and a really
nice mango salsa
oh my gosh this bread fish is delicious
it's phenomenal it's absolutely
phenomenal phenomenal absolutely
watching them eat my dish and not
knowing that it was mine and to say that
you know it looked like it was from
their heart
i'd like you to have a little taste of
that chicken fried steak i just lightly
pounded it and then fried it twice so it
should just melt in your mouth it does
melt yeah literally literally melted
chip and couldn't believe how good it
was the presentation was beautiful and
there's fresh ingredients and they
tasted wonderful they're all absolutely
phenomenal you taste the difference
absolutely
there's something you need to know about
the seafood dishes
[Music]
i didn't cook them
the two chefs put those dishes together
wow the seafood dishes
are your boys
[Music]
delicious absolutely
they really are they're phenomenal it
really opened my eyes to what i i wasn't
letting them do honestly food is art and
i was not letting them create their art
these aren't just delicious
they're beautiful and they come from
right inside you i know that you did a
fantastic job it feels really good that
daryl and ellen recognize my potential
and i think that my abilities haven't
shown and hopefully this is the first
step forward this is the music i can see
that's what we're looking for all i
could really think to myself was about
[ __ ] time you see it really good job
well done
after finally having at least a small
breakthrough with the owners jeff ramsey
decides to have his team work through
the night on the biggest restaurant
makeover they have ever done
[Music]
right good morning morning chef excited
are you ready to see the musics yes
let's go welcome to the news eggs here
we go
[Music]
oh my god let's start with the walls
gone is the swamp
look at all the the other old doorways
reclaimed doors they've got that
nostalgia and it's got that comfort
field right
look at this you've got the most amazing
chairs brand new chairs
it just feels authentic let me say this
please please you have found our
identity wonderful this is wonderful us
i'm astonished i mean truly i didn't
really have any expectations
but this has surpassed anything you
could possibly imagine
there is one more thing i'd like to show
you
you're going to start peeing your pants
there we are
at boil
oh my gosh from shocking your oysters to
cooking your shrimp this is gonna be a
substantial part of the menu and a meal
it's gonna take so much pressure off you
and jason this should just run on its
own and it should almost double the
turnover did i see you smile again
that's the second time in 24 hours dude
huh they're gonna arrest you for being
too happy jeff ramsey has given this
staff this place
my family our friends our customers a
new beginning it's unbelievable honestly
when people would ask me where i work i
would never say zekes i just say i'm a
cook
now i'm i'm proud to say that i work
here a new beginning and a new identity
physique
along with making the decor more
inviting jeff ramsey has replaced zeke's
outdated stale menu with a modern update
of classic new orleans cuisine oh my
gosh my goodness me
this is gonna put zeke's back on the map
be careful it's fresh goodness
every dish is absolutely beautiful okay
let's start off top of the table zeke's
house boil yes bucket of shrimp yes look
at the blue crabs great sharing
festive
localized bucket push them okay back in
the menu the entrees pecan crusted
catfish so with a classic tartar sauce
and a herb salad
country fried steak big hit say no more
such a gravy delicious slightly heated
in that gravy it's got a nice little
burn at the back of your throat
blackened alligator wonderful creole
sauce
absolutely delicious because this has
now become not the old zekes your zekes
thank you
you've got your identity
now make it yours absolutely incredible
beautiful come here
[Music]
the way chef created the menu and the
dishes uh they don't have a menu like
that around here dig in enjoy so not
only do we have something great to put
on the table but
it's not anywhere around nobody else has
it did you taste the cornbread i mean he
was phenomenal i'm proud to have it and
excited and can't wait for everybody
else to come in and try it it's
delicious i feel right now we have the
most diverse louisiana southern menu i
mean we very well may have the best menu
rigid flavor rich in
texture
wow
[Music]
hi guys welcome to zeke the community of
metairie had a love affair with this
restaurant that went sour enjoying joy
and joy shrimps are amazing chef
ramsay's revamp and tonight's relaunch
will be a strong indicator if it's
possible for this love affair to resume
i'm gonna try this [ __ ]
i'm gonna
and with so many changes in place and so
many people in the dining room chef
ramsay is hoping the boil house will
take some of the pressure off the
kitchen
any um any orders on there in the
boathouse no
nothing at the board house already so
get hold of the waitresses call them in
and say right start pushing them i've
got to use that place you've got to get
used to that let's go great sell boil
food sell one okay sell one to a big
table please tonight we have a um
special it's boiled lobster for two i
don't know if you saw it on the menu but
sell it by the blockage just bring us
two trips right there
two buckets of leftovers for table five
two bucks
complete let's go put a little bit of
butter on there give it a nice little
glaze okay
good that's it two lobsters let's go
look what i have for y'all y'all enjoy
it looks good
with the boil house now being utilized
and satisfying customers
it's clearly allowed some breathing room
for the kitchen you're eight minutes on
bay crab at 33. however it's now up to
daryl to manage the time wisely i worked
hard today let's make it happen you've
got to focus on that window communicate
with these guys one take one leaving one
table working so we don't get bumped
down yes yes sure
i need an alligator i need a strip give
me three minutes on that let's go we
need to push food up there and cook it
as fast as we can great tomatoes
chocolate ices and eat it fast let's
wipe one at a time it's not a race are
we looking three chops in alligator hold
on one second daryl mother chop how we
like it zero slow down for one minute
let us catch up huh [ __ ] hell with
daryl calling multiple tickets at the
same time grits mash sweet potatoes and
more focused on speed than anything else
ticket is it for the kitchen is now
completely confused how's my pecan
catfish where's my new york strips got
to go just put them in the window and
we'll figure out how to plate them yes
whatever you got make sure it's done huh
i was being told that i need this this
and this right now and i just try and
move as fast as i can and get the food
out say it just looks like crap
do you agree yeah no garnish
no go in the window like that
daryl has managed to get the cooks
producing the food at a much quicker
pace
but the dishes are not at the level that
they should be so is that food
yeah
guys the fish is raw not tonight just
just stop 24 is out everybody stop what
a joke
[Music]
it's relaunch night at six mother chop
how are we looking around slow down for
one minute let us catch up huh and with
daryl pushing the cooks food is leaving
the kitchen quickly can we get another
one
unfortunately it's also coming back
quickly guys the fish is raw not tonight
oh man just stop
everybody stop
i'm here jason come around
i'd rather be three four minutes later
than rush food out there and the shit's
coming back not tonight an expeditious
should definitely set the tone for the
rest of the kitchen i think daryl lost
control of that all right it's just a
big catastrophe what we've got to do is
focus on one table at a time
we've got to communicate don't talk to
me don't get swamped where you're at
what time what you want daryl take
responsibility
i have to stop
refocus let's get these tickets out one
at a time i need to do a better job of
communicating very simply all right guys
let's focus where you at now daryl pecan
catfish and black and alligator in his
hand daryl table one let's go move to
the next ticket i got 33 black and
alligator pecan catfish coming right now
let's go following chef ramsay's advice
of focusing on one table at a time
table ten yeah
daryl and the chefs are now in sync
please let's get this to uh 31.
like an alligator
perfectly cooked dishes are leaving the
kitchen
and are being enjoyed by thrilled
customers that's delicious
now that this restaurant is on its way
to a successful relaunch
chef ramsay is ready to spread the word
what happened with the restaurant before
why did you come here this place was
legendary and it lost its way it's now
back on the map and two new owners that
are going to start their own beginning
of a new chapter what is the feedback
you're already getting for tonight that
the food is fantastic i mean the menus
it's fabulous i highly recommend that
you come in and try it let's finish
let's finish somebody get this to 14
please he said no more tickets coming in
let's get this stuff out of here
definitely
delicious
that's a wrap jack the end of the night
the way it ended made you feel good i
think daryl showed more personality
tonight than he showed in the last few
years we still have some improvements to
make but you can see it's on the right
track nice job good night ladies thank
you thank you so much
okay
tonight was about establishing a new
zeals
and you achieved it
for my first time
in new orleans
[ __ ] me did you give me a challenge
if chef ramsay told me a week ago that
all these changes were going to happen
what am i doing i don't think i would
have really believed it guys have a
quick word with you two
amazing
look at this place the potential is huge
fantastic
it's now your zeke's run with it and
daryl
you do care
and you do have a heart a big heart
show it to your staff
indeed i will don't hide that
i'm ready to do things the right way
ready to get moving it's a new it's a
new life
it's new energy good job thank you thank
you good night
good night good night good night
[Music]
we had a lot of issues here when i first
arrived the staff were at war with the
owners the food was miserable and the
restaurant was seriously struggling for
an identity
but what i witnessed was a phenomenal
comeback and how fitting is that
that took place here in the most
resilient city across america
new orleans
week old lasagna
not so special
in the weeks that followed a glowing
report on the local news as a family as
a restaurant it's back on the map
brought a surge of customers to the
restaurant hi how are y'all
daryl and ellen are doing their best to
raise staff morale you all did an
excellent job i can't do this without
you guys and are reaching out to the
community and we really thank you all
for coming it means a lot to us thanks
split seeks back on the map
[Music]
you